oh I'm gonna be signing a national  emergency and it's been signed many  times before it's been signed by other  presidents from 1977 or so it gave the  presidents the power there's rarely been  a problem they signed it nobody cares I  guess they weren't very exciting but  nobody cares they sign it for far less  important things in some cases in many  cases we're talking about an invasion of  our country with drugs with human  traffickers with all types of criminals  and gangs we have some of the greatest  people I know they've been with me from  the beginning of my campaign almost from  the first week the angel mom's  unfortunately we have new angel moms